hi everybody
my name is amina matt i'm a phd student
at mit and i'm
in the department of materials science
uh hey everyone and my name is george
i'm also a graduate student at the
massachusetts institute of technology
um and i'll let um amina take it away
great okay so today we are really happy
to share with you
some work about how to teach material
science with wolfram language
and we'll focus on examples using the
fourier transform
i'd like you to keep in mind that this
is part of a bigger project
we are indeed writing an ambitious book
in the world farm language
that will cover material science
curriculum from undergraduate to
graduate
studies so material science stands
at the intersection of physics chemistry
engineering and is increasingly
related to computer sciences we share
the belief that
using computation to understand rather
than understanding and then computing
is the best way to learn and as steven
mentioned
during his keynote it is not so much
about teaching
how to code but it is more about how to
use computational thinking to understand
a concept
so with wolfram language students and
teachers can explore
not only the mathematics governing the
physics but they can also create tools
to
investigate and visualize concept
moreover the possibility of publishing
in a private
cloud allows people from a community to
share their own notebooks
and this infrastructure kind of material
materialize
this the possibility for such a
pedagogical
approach so today we'll illustrate this
approach focusing on the use of fourier
transform
indeed the fourier transform is a very
versatile
mathematical tool widely used in
material science to reveal the details
of
materials microstructure
characterization of structure
is a fundamental block in the fills and
finds several applications
uh in photonic materials for example
that create
a bright and vivid color mimicking
nature
as the blue of this bird or or the
bright white of the leaf beetle
but also like moire pattern that you can
see on the left
produced by the superposition of crystal
structure
or the exploration of defects in crystal
so we'll start with a simple example
from photonics to illustrate the
idea of our pedagogical approach
you can you probably know that tailoring
light and matter interaction
uh is used at different for different
ants
one is to optimize scattering
thus the whiteness of a structural color
and that can be done by designing the
disorder in a sample of colored
crystal so here we will show how we can
combine wolfram tools
to understand this disorder uh so
basically how we can
characterize quantitatively the disorder
in a 2d sample
before comparing the optical response
studio will focus
on the disorder characterization because
that's the most
interesting part with wolfram language
so let's start by doing some simple
image analysis um
i said the directory i import a picture
of my sample this picture could have
like different level of grace so i'm
going to use
a manipulate and this manipulate is
able to control the threshold of my
binarization
and i can use the minimal threshold to
get
all the particles i need to recognize so
here i would like to stop for a second
and take a step back to comment on the
pedagogical use
of a manipulate so this decision
of the value the threshold value brings
up question
and require the student to think about
how they can defend
the decision how can the answer to the
question of
why this specific value of threshold
what are the consequences
of such a decision by example here we're
interested only in the position
so it doesn't really matter if we get
the right rages
and these different tasks of justifying
a decision or taking
into account the consequences are
definitely building up
not only their understanding but also
their research skills
and that's what we want to highlight
with the wolfram uh
language let's go back to our analysis
we can use component measurement and the
centroid properties to get out each
a specific element of this image
we can then extract especially the
position of the center
and as it has been highlighted here and
i'll just make it a bit bigger
we get all the center of our different
colloidal
particles so we need we need this data
to calculate
the structure factor indeed
uh let me jump to the next slide oh
sorry this is just like the
automatization of this
function so why would you need this
position
we need this position to calculate what
we call the structure factor
which is a mathematical descriptor that
can be used to quantify the disorder of
such structure
it's basically the fourier transform of
the distances between particles
what we want uh investig to
investigating with the structure factor
value
is the spatial distribution so we are
interested in knowing if
there is any anisotropy if there is any
difference
in the distances distribution depending
on the direction
the the the meaning like the the sense
of doing that
is to see that as an influence on the
color that we will obtain
at the end and we could definitely like
in a let's say naive way code with a
brute force the calculation of the
distances
and then like this expression this is
extremely slow
so the student would have some work to
do
and work the mathematical expression i'm
pretty sure that can be done in wolfram
language
and finally code the slake calculation
of the
structural factor for all these
different
positions again this can be uh um
wrapped up sorry can be wrapped up with
the previous function
into a function that also plot the
results
and as i'd like to remind you we are
interested in
looking at different type of disorder so
here
i have different samples picture and
what you can see is that
there is some disorder but it's
difficult to infer from a visual point
of view from a visual inspection
what exactly is happening so using the
structure factor plot
we can get the answer that we're looking
for
and what i would like to highlight here
is that on the upper left when the
structure
is completely random nothing really
shows up in the structure factor plot
so you have a bunch of really random
values
but in the second plot that is here on
the upper right
you can show a specific pattern that
that
indicates a specific distribution in
this case a circle
which means that we have a peak in any
direction at the same distance
so the particles are actually
distributed in an isotropic manner
and in the two last samples you can see
that there is some anisotropy
because the circle is now an ellipsoid
showing that
it's different so from there the student
can
go further because obviously we don't
want them just to reproduce
some results we want this book and the
wolfram language
inspire the students to reach out for
highest skills of the learning process
so namely i'm thinking about creation
and the computational creation and
discovery
is crucial for the understanding so we
could ask them by example to generate
new sample with anisotropic distribution
using a lot of other methods that
in the book would find place in other
chapters so that's kind of the beauty of
all these exploration that you can jump
from like one
piece of code to another one so the code
i
quickly introduced uh to code this
structure factor
and characterize the sample and the
micro micrometer size
could be used also at other size and has
been a tool widely used at atomic scale
so when we have tools like that that
come back really often because they are
like canonical concepts
what is interesting and here i would
like to refer to steven and his keynote
he talked about the function repository
as an infrastructure
that makes sense when we want to build
on available well farm language to pass
it further and so here we have worked
the student to
implementing the fourier factor or the
fourier transform
it's indeed a great experience but later
on if we can just use the tool
we can do that um with this resource
function so here the resource function
has been loaded
and what you can see is that if i run my
tm simulator
which is this function that does the
fourier transform i get a very similar
result that what i've been coding
before so i'd like to talk a bit more
about
this resource function so
we can um maybe just before showing you
more details i'd like to highlight
why we choose to work with this resource
function
um this resource reflection repository
uh it as as we're creating this book it
real
it really makes it mandatory for us to
document
the function that we're using again and
again in a very detailed way
and that is what i'm going to show you
right now so if you were a student using
this function
for the first time you could just go to
the documentation page
which is well done as you can see and
you could
realize that you can input different
type of
input an image or a coefficient tensor
and that you uh i'll talk about
coefficient tensor
a bit later on and that just by giving
an image you can get back
both the diffraction and imaging mode of
the transmission electron
microscope um i think the best way to
to show this tm simulator function
is probably to use an example
so let me try with the hexagonal lattice
so here we just created an hexagonal
lattice
transform this lattice into an image
that has been
given as input to our resource function
so the output has four different uh
windows let's say the main one is the
diffraction pattern
as you could see it in a diffraction
mode on the upper
upper left you have the imaging mode of
the tm so the image that you have
given as input next to it
next to it you have a zoom on the part
of the reciprocal space
you are in you can change the location
of the spot you are investigating
with a locator so just by by clicking on
the
on the main image and you can select the
aperture ranges
and you see now what is actually in my
selection area
and finally on the upper right you have
the
reconstructed by inverse fourier
transform
pattern so why is that important
it's because um
in in instead of just giving to the
student a diffraction pattern
we can explain where it comes from and
the student can
explore by by himself uh the different
spot
and try to understand what is happening
so by example here if i was just like
selecting different spot let me set it
one at a time
and put the two beam condition on i
could realize that the further away i go
in my diffraction pattern the shorter is
uh my lattice periodicity
and now if i go closer the lattice
periodicity becomes larger
i could also see how the orientation is
related to where i am in my diffraction
pattern and understand what actually is
diffraction so another
example that i really like to show you
is
an example that used as input an
experimental
image so if you go further down into
application
you have a polycrystalline material but
you have also this twin boundary
that you can create analytically and
more interestingly here you have the
twin boundary from an
experimental image so the student could
apply this tool
to an image that it can find on the web
or coming from research
and here again the exploration of the
diffraction path
pattern will highlight by example
that um some of these points
show the crystal orientation happening
only at the boundaries or only on like
one side of the crystal for example this
one
so we want the
the students to be curious and at this
point they might be intrigued by how the
function works
and again with this knife and nice
function resource
they can go and see the code that i can
show to you right
here and realize that this code does
image processing when needed and then
use this like
fourier uh fast fourier transform
and finally they can also discover that
uh there is all the selection area at
the end so if you've been looking at the
documentation when i was showing it you
might have already seen that
another very neat way to create an input
is to give an analytical expression so a
linear combination of sines
and cosines and we do have an example
here
let me just scroll a bit further down so
here we have an
example of an input that has been
given with coefficient tensor so these
are the tensor of this linear
combination
and what you visualize is the
superposition of two lattices
i'll come back to that and very
interestingly
you can see that we now have like the
usual diffraction spot of the hexagonal
symmetry but on top of that we have
extra let's call them
satellites so extra bright spots
that represent a new type of periodicity
and this exploration brings me back to
material science
because we actually see that kind of
pattern in material science
so let me go back to my main page
and talk to you about murray pattern
so i mentioned really quickly in the
introduction that murray pattern are
the superposition of two letters with
different periodicities
you might have seen that in old
photographs or on
the screen of old tv when you do have
this kind of new pattern that shows up
and this happened in the field uh oh
sorry this is just an illustration
uh maybe it will make it a bit clearer
so here we have a lattice so
an array of points and if we superpose
two of them one with the initial lattice
parameter
and a second one that is like uh deleted
a bit
well when i move these
like super post lattice i can see that i
do have
a new pattern that are created so i hope
you can see that on your screen i can
see them pretty well
and this is actually also what happened
in 2d
materials so
in material science recently it's not so
recent anymore
we've been playing a lot with two
dimensional materials
uh mainly graphene and the superposition
of twisted bi-layer graphene have shown
new physical
properties that have been really
exciting also these like different
uh murray pattern can be seen with
different
microscope but we won't go into the
detail of that but that could be a way
to bridge that with experimental
technique for students
so what we want to do here and that's
like a neat feature
of this kind of pedagogical approach is
we want to build up
on the tool they've been using to go
even further
and export another topic so in this case
we want to think about
how can we explain this moire pattern
how i can
how can we explain these like new spots
and this is linked to a very
uh an important concept that that is the
convolution theorem
the convolution theorem basically says
that if you apply the fourier transform
on the product of two function it's the
same as
doing the convolution of the fourier
transform of each
function function here are the lattice
function
of our crystal and as an example
we can code like one lattice which
straight we can rotate this lattice
and then we can superpose both of them
as we will do with a bilayer material
to get this like murray pattern so this
new periodicity
and then we can do a few tricks
to simplify the fourier transform and
the dirac delta
function that results for finally
plotting the spatial frequencies
so let me just next stop on these two
graphs these represent the spatial
frequencies
of two different layers one that is
straight and what are these
oriented at 15 degrees so slightly
rotated
so what you can see in the center is the
central frequency which comes from the
one half that we have just here
and then the smallest spots represent
the
periodicity at plus and minus p over
the la is distance
so what we can do here and what with uh
as a symbolic power of mathematica is
explore this like convolution theorem by
doing first
uh the fourier transform of the of the
product of both our function which i
remind you is the left hand side of the
equation
and plot the fourier component and then
we can do a convolution
on each of the fourier transform
and plot the common the component again
both components are present
uh so we have like uh proven let's say
we have confirmed
the convolution theorem and now we can
think about the physics
so what happens here is that on top of
the frequencies of each
individual lattice which were i
i remind you the three horizontal big
dots
as well as the slightly um rotated three
other dots
we now have like four new dots which are
four new
frequencies appearing from the linear
combination
of these different layers and we can see
that these like satellites these new
dots are actually at the same distance
as
the distances between the spots of
each layer separately so the takeaway
is by superposing these two lattices
together we create a new interference
that is a new periodicity
and creates new spot in this diffraction
pattern
that can be easily illustrated by the
convolution theorem
and sorry
and from here i like to let my
co-presenter george
give you an example on how this tool can
be used as a teaching tool
but that can also be used further as a
research tool
with an example from his own research
thanks amina uh so yeah let's try this
backseat driving uh hopefully you'll be
scrolling at the same pace
um so like i mean i said this is a great
and we think the wolfram language is a
great teaching tool and a pedagogical
tool
to try and understand how these um or a
patterns work
um in general material science um but
in this particular case we applied it in
a very real sort of
you know research level uh topic and i'm
happy to report
on following sort of stephen's advice at
the keynote both those papers have
thoroughly cited the wolfram language um
so
what happens here is that you know
following on this idea of twisted
bilayered graphene when we have 2d on 2d
materials and we twist them
now we were thinking can we instead of
putting a 2d material on top of another
can we grow a three-dimensional crystal
on a 2d substrate so what this schematic
is showing which again was produced in
the wolfram language as you can probably
tell
is a 2d material substrate which is a
molybdenum disulfide that's the
purple and the yellow is the sulfur and
then what we're doing we're growing
epitaxally on it
gold so gold is a three-dimensional
material that is usually used for
contacts and leads so this is sort of
the system we wanted to
investigate uh using um
using our sort of formalism and the
question is of course how does this
first look like in real space and
experiment
so
do you have the tm image amino by any
chance or
it's okay if you don't
i don't think i have it here actually
okay uh yeah no
no worries so these things are indeed uh
sort of we can observe these on a
transmission electron microscope
and we're happy to share that image
later so this is a transmission electron
microscope
at the at the nano facility at mit
and what happens is that we observe a
super lattice this more
periodicity and it's at 18 angstroms
and now what happens is with this
convolution theorem
you know we can we can make some sort of
manipulate like this where we're
superimposing
our substrate which are the the
molybdenum purple spots and our gold
sort of the yellow spots in this
diffraction pattern
and what happens here is that contrary
to the two-dimensional two-dimensional
twists
because of the 3d nature of the layer so
as you can see the gold is stacked in
layers we get these coexisting moire
periodicities so there's two frequencies
these sort of dashed lines and each of
them come with a different more a
period so and now with this slider
you know if we sort of change the the
angle
rotation angle that the overlying gold
has on the mos2
we can see how these periods sort of
move around and they shift
and we can sort of match them to
experiment
and sort of predict the epitaxial
orientation that we would sort of
observe
in the transmission electron microscope
which in this case amino acids zero
degrees so you can feel free to take the
slider all the way to the left
thank you um so you know as we can see
we reproduced this 18 angstrom or
aperiod
and we also reproduced this slightly
larger more ep at 32 angstroms
and that is hidden in trans in
conventional tm
and in the paper we go into how one can
actually image that as well
and just sort of the last thing i wanted
to point out is the satellite peaks that
i mean i pointed out before
so though sort of if we turn on this
sort of starry night sky of all the
satellite peaks
we can sort of see how these more right
patterns can also be
quite uh beautiful to look at so i think
we're going to
stop right there sort of in time for
questions so we welcome any questions
thank you
and i mean perhaps while we wait for
questions you can pull up the tm image
from
yeah let me do this
would you like to make some comments now
that you actually have the picture on
sure i'll say a couple of things first
that scale bar uh
is set at 20 angstroms at two nanometers
so the little spots that you see near
the scale bar those are
sort of the molybdenum atoms so we can
see sort of atomic resolution
in this micrograph and then that darker
region
is the gold island as we can see sort of
on the gold island we get this sort of
embossing effect in this
larger moire pattern which um
is indeed has an 18 angstrom period
and i should i should give credit where
credit is due the this was a
collaboration
uh with uh graduate student kate reedy
and professor francis ross at mit as
well
thanks i just like edit here
and i'll add it to the file that i'll
upload later
okay um maybe we can also mention while
we have like
a few more minutes that the book is
co-authored with uh
craig carter and it's ongoing work so
if anyone is also going through the the
path of publishing a book with wolfram
language
we are really interested in sharing
ideas comments
experiences uh issues
um or if anyone uh think that they could
have a nice contribution
uh with on on the topic we are also
eager to know about it
okay so let me see if i can check
here okay so we do have a question um
several actually okay someone asked
where it was published craig already
answered
um someone else asked if you can
determine the angle of gold atoms
relative to the axis
of the mobility i guess george you can
answer that
sure yeah i'll take that next one as
well can you manufacture gold islands
with different
angles so what what happens here is this
is a epitaxial
alignment so under ultra high vacuum we
grow the gold onto the mos2
layer and uh so uh
because these are you know in
three-dimensional materials when you
cut a three-dimensional material you
have some unsatisfied bonds
and those bonds sort of then force that
material to to sort of
align on some preferred orientation so
they're epitaxial
so actually the orientations that the
gold likes to sort of
stick to is sort of the 0 30 and
sometimes 15 degrees with the underlying
substrate but when the interesting thing
is we can also do in situ experiments
where we take this and then we heat it
up
and what happens there is that we see
this gold island sort of start rotating
and jingling around
so you're 100 correct we can measure the
relative angle
of the gold looking at the diffraction
pattern of these moire
periodicities
and and just just on the other or where
this is published uh what craig
pointed out uh is the uh is a conference
proceeding paper there's also an archive
version
of this work that i'll be happy to post
in that chat as well
okay one more question from david debota
still about this golden island well i
feel like we should
talk offline david it's as we're exactly
thinking
that this will be the next project that
we look at and sort of ask the question
not only can we detect
the defects but can the visualization of
the more a period
sort of magnify the defect so if we're
thinking of say a dislocation
uh in a material can that sort of how
how does the more how will the more
uh period be affected by that and can we
amplify things like the burgers vector
for example so yeah great question zola
so it might be that people are jumping
to
different talks we are going to be
around for 10 more minutes before the
zoom
will shut down so you can just go if you
have any other question that pops up
meanwhile
okay so it seems like we don't have like
many attendees anymore so i i thank
people that have been watching this talk
and
just feel free to send question uh
through pathable
uh for further uh
for more talking
you